momento de hablar de economía quien
france24 y para ello saludo a nuestra
periodista daniela blandón que se
encuentra con nosotros en estudio de
daniela comenzamos con indicadores
porque hoy fue un día de grandes
ganancias para las bolsas del mundo
cuéntenos andrés muy buenas noches pues
podría decirse que las elecciones de
eeuu pasaron a un segundo plano por lo
menos hoy lo que agitó las bolsas fue la
esperanza sobre una vacuna contra el 19
la estadounidense pzifer y la alemana
variante k anunciaron una efectividad
del 90 por ciento de su proyecto y rusia
dijo lo mismo sobre el suyo la euforia
fue más notoria en europa andrés la
bolsa de madrid tuvo su mayor alza en
más de una década en el gráfico vemos
cómo se dispara justo después de
conocerse la noticia para cerrar con una
ganancia de casi 9% lo mismo se observó
en parís
el anuncio catapultó del índice cac-40
en cerca del 8% y pasó las 5000 unidades
el dax 30 de fráncfort hizo lo propio
subió un 4,94 por ciento en su mejor
jornada desde
el 18 de marzo pero cuando abrió wall
street ya se conocía la noticia por eso
a primeras horas llegó a tocar un máximo
histórico que no se consolidó al cierre
el dow jones hoy subió cerca del 3% y el
nasdaq bajó pero américa latina también
se contagió de ese optimismo y a nivel
internacional de cuento andrés que el
precio del petróleo w y tuvo su mayor
ascenso en seis meses del 8,48 por
ciento
daniela vamos a hablar exclusivamente de
eeuu y cuéntenos en concreto qué
significa para la economía que yo vaivén
haya ganado la selección es bueno pensar
de una victoria que tiene muy contento
al mercado yo bailé en llegar a la casa
blanca con desafíos monumentales en el
frente económico la recesión ha sido
bastante dura el convite 19 borró de un
plumazo más de un año de producción
económica el crecimiento en términos
trimestrales es decir frente al
trimestre anterior fue negativo hasta
junio y comenzó a recuperarse sólo entre
julio y septiembre y todavía está
pendiente en el congreso un segundo
paquete de ayudas
y en términos de empleo la pandemia
acabó con cinco años de crecimiento
cuando donald trump llegó era del 47 por
ciento y una de sus mayores logros los
hay que decirlo fue reducirlo hasta el
35 por ciento el menor en medio siglo
pero la pandemia volvió a dispararlo
hasta el punto más alto desde la gran
depresión de los 30 ahora está mejor
pero de los 22 millones de platos
laborales que se perdieron en la crisis
apenas se ha recuperado 12 millones
hablamos más temprano con claudio loser
quien es ex director para el hemisferio
occidental del fondo monetario
internacional
evidentemente el presidente electo
bailén va a recibir una economía en un
estado complicado y diferente de lo que
recibió obama en su momento porque
todavía el kobe está presente lo cual
genera mayor grado de incertidumbre en
términos de la recuperación pero nos
encontramos con una economía que tiene
un altísimo desempleo que todavía
requiere de un programa de estímulo
importantísimo pero cuáles son los
principales puntos del programa
económico del presidente electo andrés
joe biden diseñó un plan de
reconstrucción llamado building back
better o reconstruir mejor que promete
crear millones de trabajos entre esos
pilares están políticas contra el cambio
climático y más inversión en
manufacturas así como en tecnologías
limpias también retomar el obamacare
para garantizar el servicio de salud
universal pero quizás una de sus
propuestas son más
ha sido el alza de los impuestos a los
más adinerados y más regulación para
empresas su agenda incluye elevar de
nuevo el impuesto de renta para
sociedades del 21 al 28 por ciento como
observamos en la pantalla también
imponer sobre tasas a quienes se
traslade en sus puestos de trabajo a
otros países por el lado de los
ciudadanos quienes ganen más de 400 mil
dólares al año serían gravados con un
39.6 por ciento y no con el 37 por
ciento vigente veamos que dice nuestro
analista al respecto
lo que quiere hacerse es retrotraer las
medidas que tomó trump y el congreso
republicano entre el 17 y el 18 pero no
no para todos los casos fundamentalmente
no se quiere tocar demasiado en los
impuestos de la clase media sino
aumentar la tasa marginal de impuesto a
la renta es decir qué
va creciendo la tasa con el nivel de
ingresos y en la parte corporativa ahí
es bastante complicado porque se redujo
la tasa
corporaciones óseas
a las grandes empresas para que pudieran
competir mejor con con otros países
incluido en europa así que ahí también
se quiere subir el impuesto pero creo
que va a ser como decimos nosotros más
cuesta arriba va a ser más difícil pasar
esto pero todas estas reformas
dependerán por supuesto de lo que pase
en el congreso que es el que finalmente
les da el sí o el no la cámara de
representantes- sigue dominada por los
demócratas hasta el momento pero en el
senado ambos partidos están empatados en
estas elecciones a falta de definir
cuatro asientos si los republicanos
mantienen la mayoría a joe biden le será
más difícil impulsar su agenda liberal
como en su momento le ocurrió a barack
obama pero si quedan empatados andrés
entra un personaje clave
kamala harris quien será la encargada de
los desempates
daniela este es un programa económico
para eeuu pero usted nos va a contar
cómo es que esto impacta en américa
latina y en el resto del mundo si antes
porque yo apuesto que sus amigos y sus
familiares le han preguntado pero a
nosotros porque nos tiene que interesar
eeuu y es que eeuu es el primer o uno de
los primeros socios comerciales en todo
el mundo son 300 millones de personas
pues por supuesto consumiendo productos
pero si hay un país clave en la región
es cuba la isla ha sido objeto de una
escalada de sanciones durante el
gobierno de trump escuchemos a nuestro
analista
no conozco los detalles pero yo creo que
va a haber una actitud más y más
elástica en tercios un poco cínicos
yo diría dado que el voto
cubanoamericano fue muy a tramp en la
florida donde están concentrados yo creo
que el país del no debe sentir que le
debe mucho y creo que va a buscar un
poco más de digamos de eliminación o
reducción de medidas restrictivas a cuba
no es que van a ver un cambio
fundamental pero yo diría que se
volvería de alguna manera a una relación
bilateral un poco de más
constructiva y américa latina no está en
el radar de economía política de los
eeuu es importante en méxico por
supuesto es muy importante pero ahí no
se va a tocar el nada respecto al
tratado reciente
by den va a ir a un sistema de
cooperación internacional que atrás no
tenía y eso yo creo que va a ayudar a la
región
pero también en el resto del mundo hay
rencillas con china con la unión europea
de hecho este lunes bruselas bruselas
aprobó imponer de inmediato aranceles a
productos de eeuu por 4 mil millones de
dólares anuales pero también invitó a
negociar a eeuu ante daniela muchísimas
gracias por explicarnos todas estas
aristas de este tema que es de eeuu pero
aquí usted nos está contando cómo es que
nos involucra a todos en el mundo a
seguir la información económica
continúen con toda nuestra programación
aquí en france 24
[Música]